[Music]
on this sunday night
no apology from the pope
[Music]
the mounting pressure on the catholic
church as canada comes together
to mourn a survivor shares his harrowing
experience
inside the kamloops residential school i
could hear
my friends and that
[Music]
crying getting dragged dragged
downstairs
plus the lasting legacy of the nova
scotia home for colored children
and a burning cargo ship loaded with
plastic
sinks off sri lanka the immeasurable
cost to the ocean
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
our nasser good evening
and thank you for joining us the
catholic church has been facing mounting
pressure to take responsibility for its
role
in canada's residential school system
and today
pope francis broke his silence saying
he's pained by the discovery of unmarked
graves
at a former residential school in
kamloops bc
he offered prayers and sympathy but no
formal apology
something many indigenous canadians and
even the prime minister have been
calling for
david aiken has our top story tonight
as a catholic on friday canada's
catholic prime minister had a message
for his church
it's going to be a really important
moment for all of us particularly
catholics across the country
to reach out in our local parishes
to reach out to bishops cardinals and
make it clear that we expect
the church to take up and step up and
take responsibility
for its role in this on sunday at the
vatican
pope francis responded the kamloops
indian recipient cell school
francis said he was pained to learn of
the kamloops discovery
and urged canadian political and
catholic leaders to quote
cooperate with determination but he did
not offer an apology on behalf of the
church or
indicate one was being considered and he
was silent on demands in canada
for the release of documents about
residential school children
the church is believed to be holding
getting access to those documents
was a key aim of the truth and
reconciliation commission
is also a sad commentary on the lack of
the
commitment by the catholic church to
allow us to
investigate this further moreover roman
catholic entities have also paid only
3.7 million dollars of the 25 million
they were to pay
as part of a settlement agreement the
peace of the lord be with you
but in toronto archbishop thomas
cardinal collins
pushed back on trudeau's comments and
called them
unhelpful i think it'd be very good
instead of making these
remarks which are really quite unfair i
would say
let mr trudeau and and his
representatives work together with us
we're trying to do that
collins also said any catholic entities
withholding documents
should promptly release them and at a
special mass
for those who died and were abused at
residential schools
collins did read an excerpt from a 1991
apology
offered by the oberlates the catholic
order that operated the kamloops
residential school
we wish to apologize in a very
particular way
for the instances of physical and sexual
abuse that occurred in those schools
still many canadian politicians and
indigenous leaders
are calling for more from the catholic
church and are expected to press the
church
in the days ahead david aiken global
news
ottawa
hundreds of people marched through
toronto today to honor the 215 children
found in unmarked graves in bc and
to demand justice for more reaction to
the pope's comments we're joined by paul
johnson he's
in kamloops bc for us tonight paul has
the to come loops to schweitman
first nation responded pharah we are not
expecting a reaction to the pope's
comments this weekend i talked to a
spokesperson
for the tekem loops to schwepn first
nation and they say they're expecting
to put out their next news release early
this coming week
so if there's going to be a reaction to
those comments from the vatican we'll
look for it then
we did talk to some indigenous people in
kamloops today who told us
sure if the pope were to apologize about
residential schools in canada
that would be better than nothing but
their sense also seems to be
an institution like the catholic church
is a very
remote thing it's never been a positive
force in their lives
so there's really nothing the pope could
say that could change that
what was meaningful to some we spoke
with was what non-indigenous british
colombians did this weekend
a 250 truck convoy that traveled across
the interior of bc to kamloops sunday
and a motorcycle rally that came through
here
here were some of the voices from that
we stand in solidarity
with the first nations and we hear them
loud and clear
now it's time for canada to hear them
loud and clear
i think it's really important that the
canadian first nations
across canada understand that we stand
here in solidarity
and we support you and we're sorry it
took so long
but we're here now and we support
the investigation of all of the
residential schools
nationwide so looking forward the
takeout loops to schwett mcfirst nation
say
they expect that they're going to be
releasing some of the technical details
about this discovery
later this month farah
paul johnson and kamloops bc thank you
paul
a former kamloops residential school
student is encouraging fellow survivors
to seek professional help douglas
heisen-ustash says counseling has helped
him in the past
but the shocking discovery of children's
remains left him
grappling with so much trauma he spoke
to global's nitu garcia
and a warning the content of this story
is disturbing
here in downtown kamloops it's sadly not
hard to find a residential school
survivor
living out much of their life on the
city streets
douglas heisen-ustash is one of them his
story is heartbreaking and hard to hear
but he wanted to try and share it he
says to let out some of his pain
and help people understand what his
experience in the former kamloops
residential school
did to him and how that recent discovery
brought it all back
i didn't know there
could be little kids that were buried
there in
it and it broke down pretty bad
i was there from 71 to 75
and i could hear my friends and that
[Music]
crying getting dragged dragged
downstairs whatever
eustace's story is a tragic testament to
the trauma
tied to the country's colonial past and
the recent discovery here has reopened
wounds
so deep he says he can't sleep at night
he told us he wanted to share his story
but it brought up so much pain
he was unable to continue his interview
with us i wanted to get out there so bad
but
i was raped and abused mentally
physically
sexually and all that
you know i hear about all these kids
that might be my family over there
buried too
i can't do this
and this is a depiction of the
devastation he deals with
daily but as i sat with him and in the
hours after this moment
he told us he's determined to continue
trying to heal
for the sake of future generations nitu
garcia global news
kamloops bc
alberta's premier jason kenney is under
fire tonight from within his own party
over recent comments about canada's
first prime minister
and a photo showing kenny having a meal
and drinks with a small group of elected
officials
and staff now he maintains the meeting
respected kovid 19 rules and
restrictions
but as heather urux west explains his
own cabinet ministers are demanding an
apology
alberta's premier says he's done nothing
wrong
we had a business dinner which we moved
outside
with six people that was fully rule
compliant mr speaker
but the photo taken on june 1st has
sparked outrage from members of kenny's
own
cabinet any public criticism from a
cabinet minister in the canadian system
is significant it's not something that
we see
leela ahir alberta's minister of culture
multiculturalism and status of women
addressed the premier's comments in a
facebook post from her personal account
on saturday
i am confused and like you extremely
hurt
and i'm so sorry for any pain anger or
frustration this may have caused you
all of us make mistakes but this one is
a big one
our leadership should sincerely
apologize
community and social services minister
rajan sani made similar comments in an
interview in punjabi with the calgary
radio station red fm
this photo my photo like this you will
not see because i would never do this
the public health measures that are in
place for our residents we have to take
very seriously
if a mistake is made then one should
apologize
notably they haven't called for a
resignation like others have
calling for the premier's resignation
instead they're simply calling for an
apology but i think an apology is a bit
too little too late
minister ahir's post also addressed the
premier's comments this week about
canada's first prime minister
and cancel culture comments the premier
defended sunday
in an interview on the roy green show i
don't think it's helpful
to sort of drive out of our history
so many of those who built the country
but in ahir's post
she disagreed writing that castle
culture happens to first nations
when atrocities and those responsible
are not acknowledged
within alberta's government there
appears to be a growing divide
heather urex west global news calgary
nhl athletes can breathe a little easier
over canada's strict
pandemic travel rules ottawa has just
approved
travel exemptions for the league as a
national interest
as the stanley cup playoffs near their
end u.s and canadian teams can now
travel into canada without a quarantine
but they will be subject to regular
covid19 testing and they must live
inside a modified bubble
now across the country the pandemic has
forced retailers to pivot their
businesses in order to survive
but one sector can't the 33 duty-free
shops along the u.s canada border
as michael couture explains they need
travel to resume so
they can get back to business it's
depressing to come into a dark
building it's it's a bit devastating
it's been nearly 15 months since
any customer has set foot in chris
foster's duty-free store
like the 32 others along the canada u.s
land border
this one north of niagara falls has been
family run for decades
the longest closure up until now was 9
11
and that was a day and a half so as you
can imagine
it pales in comparison the duty free
can't pivot in the pandemic to online or
curbside sales when something leaves
this store
it has to leave the country it can't be
sold locally
or even given away so these pallets of
year-old chocolate bars
all of this will end up in our dumpster
in the very near future it represents
around quarter of what we would
normally have on our shelves upstairs
this one's good till november
and then anywhere there's empty racks
those are products that have already
expired that we already had to destroy
there's a lot of empty racks in jeff
butler's duty-free store
amazingly he's managed to stay open
thanks to this overnight service window
that was installed 20 years ago but was
barely used
before last march and then with the
pandemic all of a sudden
we realized that that was probably going
to be the best way to ensure the safety
of our customers and our staff
it's managed to keep some sales going
like for tobacco products but
they only get trucker traffic right now
that's just a trickle we're down over 92
percent in total sales
our leading category normally would be
liquor and beverage alcohol sales
they're down over 98 percent the
association representing canadian
duty-free stores wants the borders
reopened but in the meantime
they need an extension on emergency
benefit programs
until tourism returns to normal we're
the hardest hit of the hardest hit
we need those programs until we get back
on our feet we need them into 20 20
22. federal officials say the new canada
recovery hiring program could provide
additional subsidies for those suffering
businesses
as for the border reopening the
government says it continues to consult
health experts
about easing travel restrictions michael
couture global news ottawa
coming up donald trump reemerges the
former president takes the stage
again still spouting falsehoods
he's been banned from facebook and
twitter but former u.s president donald
trump returned to the spotlight on stage
at a political rally last night
as jennifer johnson reports he wasted no
time claiming
yet again the 2020 election was stolen
from him
and he hinted at another run for the
white house
[Music]
former u.s president donald trump was
back in his element on a political stage
rallying his base joe biden and the
socialist democrats are the most radical
left-wing administration in history
a poll taken two weeks ago shows nearly
half of republican voters would support
trump
if he ran again in 2024 despite being
the only president in u.s history to be
impeached twice
trump is already hitting on familiar
campaign themes you look at our border
is wide open illegal immigration is
skyrocketing at a level that we've never
seen before
and the former president supports new
voting restriction laws recently passed
in florida georgia and texas
that democrats say will suppress the
minority vote we must eliminate the
absurdity of mass mail in voting and
people should vote in person on election
day
not over weeks and months where all
sorts of things can
happen trump and his wife have
repeatedly voted by mail
including in florida's municipal
elections three months ago
president joe biden was also rallying
his base saturday night
speaking to wisconsin's democratic party
convention
nothing in this country is more sacred
than the right to vote
you've done incredible work but we can't
let up now
biden told his supporters he's focusing
on his job now
building a stronger post-pandemic
america while the man he just beat
hints at another run at the white house
jennifer johnson global news
washington ahead a disaster in sri lanka
puts a spotlight on earth's plastic
pollution problem
there's an environmental disaster
happening off the coast of sri lanka
after a container ship sank close to its
capital colombo
spilling fuel and billions of tiny
plastic pellets
used to make shopping bags into the
ocean as redmond shannon reports it's
another wake-up call
to reduce our plastic output the cleanup
task is immense on top of the chemicals
in the sunken mv
express pearl are billions of these
so-called
nerdls tiny plastic pellets used to make
plastic bags
washing up on sri lankan beaches
oceanography experts
say it's a brutal combination from a
man-made disaster this is the worst to
hit sri lanka
the government has banned fishing for an
80-kilometer stretch of coast
our modelling says that these pellets
will
in about 40 to 50 days we'll probably
end up in indonesia
ingested by sea life these pellets will
eventually find their way into the food
chain
just as used plastics do a 2019
government study says canadians go
through
more than three million tons of plastic
a year
less than a tenth is recycled most goes
to landfill
but tens of thousands of tons end up as
litter
on land and in the sea worldwide it's
thought at least
5 million tons ends up in the sea each
year
if we don't do anything to curb the flow
of plastic
both our consumption and the flow of it
into the oceans the situation is going
to get
much worse with plastic waste and
plastic pollution quadrupling by the
year 2040.
the canadian government wants to ban six
single-use plastic items by the end of
this year
some are already banned in certain
provinces and campaigners
say more measures are needed so instead
of looking for another single-use
material
the government should be looking for
ways to incentivize the transition away
from single use entirely
and towards reuse and refill systems as
governments
move forward pandemic ppe seems to have
pushed us
two steps back the amount of plastics
that are generated
worldwide since the outbreak began
is estimated at 1.6 million tons
daily covert 19 has seen packaging
gloves and
polymer surgical masks pile up across
the world
these plastics once they are disposed of
or discarded into the environment they
do not
degrade they do not bow degrade the
effects of the pandemic on society could
last for decades
the effects on our oceans could last
centuries
redmond shannon global news london
global national will be back in just a
moment but before the break a special
announcement
prince harry and megan announced today
they have welcomed their second
child their new daughter lilibet diana
or lily for short
she was born this past friday she's
named after queen elizabeth's family
nickname and of course harry's late
mother
princess diana we'll return shortly
as the country has a difficult but much
needed conversation about the tragedy of
the residential school system
nova scotia is commemorating a
long-standing symbol of racial
segregation
in its own history the former home for
colored children
opened in the halifax area 100 years ago
today
the facility provided care for thousands
of orphaned and homeless african nova
scotian youth
who were not allowed into orphanages
with white children
global's jesse thomas looks at the
site's legacy and its future
the pandemic has just reshaped
the whole world including our world
committee members were planning an open
house for the 100th anniversary of the
nova scotia home for colored children
construction of a replica building is
nearly complete but provincial pandemic
safety measures
won't allow for an in-person gathering
so they're going virtually it's
important
to the history of nova scotia so
we're really really proud of what we've
put together
the home first opened to support black
children who were not allowed in white
institutions
you picture a hundred years ago three
thousand
people meeting black people meeting
for one exciting thing and you know that
was
back that time was big because black
kids colored kids helped go back that
far
weren't allowed in any other orphanage
so built their own art and pitch
but after it closed in the 1980s stories
from former residents began to emerge of
physical
psychological and sexual abuse shedding
light on the systemic racism and the
racial segregation
that existed at the time prompting
lawsuits a settlement and apologies
on behalf of my ministers our my caucus
our government we are sorry
in 2019 a restorative inquiry into the
abuse at the home
helped validate the stories of the
survivors spencer collies says today
feels like a new way forward
things have happened i mean everything
wasn't
didn't run smooth and in the later years
but i mean we can't
we gotta move on and try to make a
difference
and i mean it's not just here that it
happened it happened in all
institutions of this type akuma family
center now operates the home
it says it wants to develop the land to
create an afrocentric community for
multi-generations to come together
to support one another and thrive we're
moving in the right direction
and i know that there's so much
opportunity
yet to be realized jesse thomas global
news dartmouth nova scotia
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm farah nasser
[Music]
tonight we leave you with commemorations
in france
for the anniversary of d-day 77 years
ago today
when allied forces stormed the beaches
of normandy during the second world war
thousands of soldiers died fighting for
freedom
a sacrifice never forgotten
[Music]
at the going down of the sun and in the
morning
we will remember
[Music]
blah